yes come to this video
that's important in german yes i'm making
a video in german again after a
long time
there is also a very specific reason
for it
and that is there is a challenge to
a stupid comment as it is called in
english or how should you open
translate german so two players
play each other both comment
in the video yes i have
done that several times last time against good master
niclas huschenbeth in october and yes
we will do the whole thing again
not against niklas but this time other german grandmasters will step on the
gas  he has about 2500
euros and 2013 grandmaster works for
jazz tränke on the same platform
that niklas played on and he
will also comment in german and
that's why a video is also
in german that we both act in the
same language on the  channel
of jazz trendy before then his video will
be shown
yes i have the challenge
g assume that play four minutes and
two seconds come and so it's a
bit longer yes this time and
see what we can get you pulled here
actually i didn't really want to have something like
that but land here
ok ok c3 so the five knight a3 is
pretty uncomfortable  for black yes
nothing comes from nothing
grandmaster child the theory yes okay i
am not with the queens
from level 3 the problem here is the
problem move i think the pawn 7 comes
that players are under fire what
black should not do is capture
c3 instead of with it  c7 well i
stumbled into
this line a little bit he
doesn't play it that demanding with four
plays something calm but not the
case
let's see so the whole thing
is not tragic but not necessarily
my dream position
let's see well bishop  ii 39
actually looks totally normal but
the evening doesn't pick that up much springer b5
i'll follow up  the eight back nothing was
not enthusiastic but i have to
this sex c5 is pretty good
i think black has very big
equalizing problems afterwards the whole thing is also
this whole opening for black again
a book is discussed that means the
sniper this book by the english
many masters  charlie story and
take it in english i
don't think it's particularly convincing for
black but ok i'm here now people
more or less stumbled in what
exactly is because a4 fan suit well that doesn't look
very much
like the amish again something threatens me
there  mbabi threesome could be that the train
miami is coming so should i play i
'm six somehow this jumper annoys me a
lot
i'll get it back okay he does
n't go to the fia after three
i didn't expect that but
okay like that if  I now play the six games
with it it's uncomfortable really
uncomfortable jump f65 it's not nice jumper
g4 gek  lops 7
well ok that's not tragic
maybe maybe i can take the
game
i'm going i5 at the end from springer
ag 49 57 king to 7 springer ag from the
state king back the four-in-hand rose
i think that's natural in
principle it really has to  make
e5 I could go after four now
but then that's where the 5 comes from
that's really embarrassing yeah well I've
seen seven more runs but I
thought that's not so bad for
me to have
a look problem is of course my
king has drawn and accordingly
accordingly i wo
n't be able to start the game anymore
what speaks for me is that the
knight on a3 is of course quite a
cucumber well that's not a small
dream position and doing what's going on
here five is certainly a
move i would like to make maybe
not being able to court the six or runner
f5 that sucks running five
with the threat runner the 31 that it doesn't
ht beautiful and h6 are also a
stupid move but how do I ever get
my king out of the quark so to speak
I'll try try times like this
king 11 7 million
that's ugly but I have to
somehow bring the 28 into
play thom f8 king g8  for the
artificial skin
the only thing i have here of course
is the pair of runners which of course i
always like duration the whole
coordination of the position is only very
very problematic well he four is
certainly possible or people f4
thom once a vote once
maybe not  doing f1 also
looks like he might be a king but he can still
do something with 45 moves or something like that he
four maybe f4 knight g4 h3
knight f6 knight ag 5 like that
but i can go to g8 i didn't have to
take it that's not so bad
maybe  for black well the whole
position is somehow like that if i
don't fly right off the plate
then always black isn't so
bad
i ha  be with two central pawns and
two bishops well there comes with that with
the train goes here yes I go there
to g4 and then five is he five is
stupid but I didn't see five
after public big problem
then of course found
yes I did  i saw too late now
i saw after i drew
it no matter how i take my players
is a way they have i have to
return
this is of course anything but a party
here the as the king has to get out
bad bad so that the 3 so that the three
could just come but i have to
hit or well king g8 is really
terrible
well what should i do no choice
but so that the three is just strong
then of course he takes on the
queen my king has 0 squares and bishop
r15 becomes a tasteless with the tone
hit
you can't believe that I ca
n't be made there you can't believe
well with double chance and everything zipp and
zapp bad
well I have to pull something like that here that is
the only horrible position
that can also play faster the
rest was clearly lost
knight e5 or what comes I do
n't know it horrible position
the five is a complete bulkhead yes I
don't know it has to happen again
somehow it has to look like I'm going to
lose right away
maybe it's not which
westend i'm just a professional optimist
but also do
6 well that's negligible of course also
five and so but on the 6 1 rooms
that also looks very dangerous i
could now here next to theoretically
theoretically runner he 50 also bad
yes okay me  do that now 6 wins
then wins what should i do
well i don't see exactly how
he wins it of course very dangerous he
doesn't win right away he
just says okay that's so fat
all the time now somehow do it
okay i'm  satisfied but with he will
not be satisfied since the g4 arrive
example once matrons debattier  en
if nothing else works at least once
market have threatened so and you can
fumble around here somehow otherwise it wo
n't work
springer iv or the funny moves here
springer 4s in move
no matter where move i only have 18
seconds and the whole thing needs
a medium difficulty here anyway  miracle for
surviving now
here it is hanging but also here at the
moment fruit is hanging overlooked the
position was natural was of course
inhuman to defend with no
time
ok I have to give that up where is he
giving up I haven't given up here that often
well that wasn't  so good the position
was really bad the position was bad
ok look black let's see with white
let's see what he can do I make
a revenge demand with white
can equalize here with the 4
yes it was somehow I don't think
that maybe it worked in the meantime
again but in the practical part it
was terribly hard to hold
i think so dora six j  ear do
I speak f3 that's how it was yes you can
do everything
it's not that uninteresting for
black leads to interesting
mood pictures black often exchanges on
f3 makes the double pawn and then says
for example on the black
squares try to get a game
also works fairly often
you look the whole thing is complicated
springer h6 is the typical plan
didn't do well at all then i prevent
that sometimes springer h 65 is a typical
plan in its position okay he
just plays sometimes just just plays
but actually has here points
more or less fast g5 you should
play two bishops more or less without
replacement so in any case it is
comfortable for white
let’s see knight b6 back then five
such moves can be considered for
black there is already 5 back then yes
i could take it now and knight
ag 15 but of course that
doesn't really help anymore, it just
works again  r back well normal actually f4
so you have 053
he I would like to take that on the five
that is of course at the moment
I still have a bad knight the 5
so that's good at the moment that he has
just prevented these knights the
five knights 7  motive if the question
is I would also like to take
c6 well interesting I'll take it now
because it's just the five
slowly begins to black to
be okay the position here is still quite
pleasantly deserted because it's not so clear
what black really makes the five
maybe as i don't
always put the players 53 on this long
diagonal i can
still try to play on the line
against the pawn e7 it takes a
while but there is still a
plan
he is so clear that
should make black  So not that it's that
terrible, but you can't do much actively now,
I really think the five are still
interesting maybe  Is that possible
or more
likely I think it's definitely possible
but I also think it's quite possible as a
plausible move
well well but the five doesn't really threaten anything
now so district eps calderone
okay he just goes back that's not that
bad definitely ok I wanted him
live 13
there it says there I think quite well asks
black was there now does a lot said that
's it's a bit that's a
bit thankless for black because there
really aren't that many plans
that you can play
yes that's one of the few  I was thinking about
springer four
then being ready for game five
but okay that doesn’t have to be so
great for me sprenger
münster well I don’t want to beat him
I drew one that fits into
the position anyway if the spring tide makes it
I can do it  well yes it's not totally
stupid but of course there's a
lot of black fields well
actually that's stupid only 15 to
beat I can tour better  en
to pull the order on a4 is an
amplifier on already five times in the direction of
b1 in berlin really take power is
not good the bad you always come
to the leuphana t4 or
another character the springer jacoby
one i have to play anyway does not exist
suspension not much to think about who
is really not that easy at the for
knows now how to find a clear way
forward
i can play the four villages
next turn and then attack seven times
but of course you can
cover it so he wants the five
play yes I understand that well let
me think about it can I operate there somehow
tactically with tactically
he would have to take with the he would yes with the
pawn which is
actually not so nice
actually I can't believe
that it's so great with  the one with the g5
would be i'll do it now that's a
complicated position
maybe he wants to play a completely different way
just the pawns
vo  put 06 as a precaution yes then
i can of course take it is of course
total crap but i can here i
can dollar 710 and
tickle the sound a bit of the 11 it's not
really clear how i can get on here i
'm really not quite
sure check these errors here  c5
maybe so that you look three times
i have more time so i'm
not satisfied with my moves i'm
honest but i didn't want to
think about it forever and try
to play reasonably fast well
i don't want to accept it so
much because now i'll do that  people
that the tower is a little out of place
or do I go back after three a
little star I don't know exactly how
to give it away
so now he wants to go to f5 ok I
just have to ask what actually happens
if I just sacrifice it all
up  the 5 since we are five in the end
somehow looks a bit harmonious
for black he has a bishop f8 close to the end
but just about  de just so just just
if not
difficult to say
connection interrupted not really
i was i can't think of exactly
what i should
do i thought i could maybe sacrifice
but it doesn't look like it
would have there springer f60 plays that
really stupid like that stupid  connection
was really interrupted
no idea i'm still
running my connection is interrupted now
my or i don't know weird just
okay i keep my 50 clock under
control
that's not so nice i think all
jumpers then of course also a
bit a bit shaky
stands for  tactics can also be f3 i
can't play right away that doesn't matter
much
now it leads to interesting
positions here 25 times there for women c
3 well it's not that bad
black is
black is clear it's not like that
it's not like that in a way  to snap away
ok i can beat him
i can really just take them
and if i again  he came up in
this game but still
quite good because we play six chess but
ok that doesn't bother
me ok it's a quality and I'll I'll get it
mitchell 6 in the end material
is pretty important yes I
actually have  played stupidly so somehow it
wasn't really
anything but say yes what can you say the
first game was the opening
catastrophe and here I somehow
didn't understand much either but
somehow it still worked out in the end
and I could pose problems whereby
f60 six times of course  everyone who is close
therefore a bit uncomfortable even
before black i think the
this whole king's position here with a
knight on g7 looks shaky so
here i think i
really have a
bit of an advantage for the first time in the game
ok after the opening i had it too
which but still nothing bad
and here I think it's
really quite good for quite g  ut vor knows
without winning right now or
something like that 11 6 of course helped a lot
yes ok duel games in the
first I got really terrible 1 on the
ass but at least
balanced here now
yes I hope it was fun times in
German these games  to have commented
and yes definitely check out the
jazz twenty four
channel the youtube channel of the server they
will also put the games in there
then you can compare
maybe he didn’t understand anymore
in the second game i then
much now pulled back and forth so
it was difficult for me yeah thanks
for seeing see you soon